hey what's going on it's bill burr in
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast how are you doing what's going
on oh and I'm just checking in on you
how you doing - you feeling good you got
a sore throat are you worried about your
Nana Corona everybody's freaking out
it's great I love it I have never
enjoyed people freaking the [ __ ] out
more than I have with this coronavirus
this boyband level of freaking out oh my
god everybody acting like a bunch of
[ __ ] teenage chicks freaking out
about the latest boy panel
kuroh oh oh corona virus grow oh it's
gonna kill you just take some vitamin C
get [ __ ] eight hours sleep wash your
[ __ ] hands and even if you get it
you're gonna ride it out you never saw
these videos of these guys getting bit
by rattlesnakes and they just [ __ ]
sitting there biting down on a stick for
a few days hallucinating they get
through that I think you'll be fine
however please keep freaking out it's
the right thing to do freaking out it's
the right thing to do
don't don't trust your neighbor wash
your [ __ ] hands cuddle your kids keep
them the [ __ ] away from other [ __ ]
people right that's what you want to
[ __ ] do okay and I love all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] everybody's overreacting
out of proportion this is what I say to
all those people and what medical degree
do you have and how many times have you
been in a position of power where it was
up to you to handle a pandemic then shut
the [ __ ] up I don't think
anybody's overreacting to be honest with
you I don't I like people that are
overreacting there's a lot of people
overreacting but they're dumb you know
what I mean
like here's one for you okay these
[ __ ] college kids freaking out about
how they can't go back to their
dormitories right so my first thought
was what kind of a [ __ ] idiot wants
to go to school I don't want to go to
school you know I guess if you're the
quarterback and you're banging all these
hot chicks you're like well what the
[ __ ] it's my nightclub
throw the [ __ ] thing through the air
and somebody catches it and all these
prods want to suck my dick and I
understand those people not want to go
back I understand people who you know
maybe you got nowhere to go like I know
where else to go
right you're [ __ ] you're from another
country you know your parents never
loved you they couldn't wait you know
they didn't marry for love they just
they had a lustful moment you were born
they were waiting - you were 18 so they
could [ __ ] break up and send you off
to school and you got nowhere to go I
understand that but the rest of them I
don't [ __ ] understand right
and then my mouth-breathing friends are
like yeah dude I wouldn't go to school
you know I'd be [ __ ] staying home
[ __ ] playing cards with all my friends
see right there that's the leak in the
balloon right there it's how dumb the
average [ __ ] person is okay they're
gonna tell you not to go to school
because there's a virus out there and
then what is your dumb ass do like self
quarantine is that it's just it's not
gonna [ __ ] work people are too
[ __ ] stupid they're too [ __ ]
selfish to even [ __ ] understand I'm
not gonna stay in my household hey do
you know I saw this [ __ ] idiot right
am I gonna [ __ ] interact with my
neighbors
that's Gail I can't not answer the door
if it's Gail right you got all of those
[ __ ] people all right
and then you get this [ __ ] idiot
alright and I saw this guy it was on
[ __ ] Twitter so you know it's true
this guy goes I'm an American in Italy
they've shut down the whole country it's
a nightmare
what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] are you
that you're in Italy and they've shut
down the whole country and you can't go
outside and you think it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
how selfish are you huh oh I can't go on
the gondolas you know with some guy go
and no mood it's your eye like a big
pizza pie I got on a striped shirt huh
anybody can go to Italy and eat [ __ ]
spaghetti go there and take the dumbass
too [ __ ] long tour the Roman
Colosseum always this way the Lions were
I went to the Roman Colosseum I walked
around it myself I'm gonna [ __ ] sit
there with goddamn headsets on as you
explain every [ __ ] piece of rubble in
there I don't give a [ __ ] I know what
happened here all right
this is the first sports arena they were
too dumb to just play baseball football
basketball or hockey so they [ __ ]
threw people the line said that's all I
need to know I understand all right yeah
people what guys walked around in
miniskirts and they [ __ ] threw people
the lines okay great great do I need you
to tell me everybody's [ __ ] name and
then after Caesar
King Luigi the 19th oh my god [ __ ]
kill me please somebody breathe on me or
you could be in Italy all right when the
entire country is shut down and you get
to peek out your [ __ ] window look
down this street and see what it would
be like if you were the last man on
earth and then you come back to the
states with that story and I want you to
meet one [ __ ] person that went to
Italy that can top your story
everybody's gonna go there and get some
[ __ ] octopus
some [ __ ] pizza everybody's gonna get
on the [ __ ] gondola the Roman
Colosseum ooh ooh ooh the Leaning Tower
of Pisa do you know you can't go up in
it anymore right everybody's gonna
[ __ ] do that but who can actually
[ __ ] sit in there in their [ __ ]
hotel room for their entire [ __ ]
vacation petrified wondering if they're
ever going to be allowed back into their
own country alright now that that is a
vacation for the [ __ ] ages that is
not a nightmare that is a unique
experience alright but the problem with
the human brain is the human brain as a
99% tendency to want to do what
everybody else is doing I want to do
what everybody else is doing it I'm in
the herd so now I feel safe God for
[ __ ] bid you go to Italy and you get
a unique experience I mean that's right
being shut in in Italy and not being
able to leave your room and going out
and eating that wonderful food that you
can smell is right up there with like if
you went to Sicily and you were eating a
slice of pizza and you happen to see a
mob hit you know but you know those you
know you don't to be around something
like that see somebody's brains get
blown out you know you don't want that
on your [ __ ] hard drive blood
splatter and now you're part of the
crime scene and they're [ __ ] putting
yellow tape around you and you're like I
have a flight to catch they don't give a
[ __ ] right you don't want any part of
that but sitting in that [ __ ] room
do you [ __ ] believe that I mean how
long are they gonna keep those people in
there five six weeks
I don't know I'm usually anti-authority
but I'm gonna go I'm gonna go out on a
limb here and I'm gonna I'm gonna go
with the government on this one how
they're handling this
okay cuz this is how I look at the
government all right the government
wants you to stay alive because if you
die they can't exploit you anymore so
they don't want a bunch of people that
they're making money off of to die we're
all assets to them alright is dumb as a
person can [ __ ] be they're still
taking part of your paycheck right they
can still put boots on you and send you
somewhere to stand in the way of some
[ __ ] that should be hitting them right
so they don't want you to die so I feel
if they think that what these
precautions that they're taking is is
necessary then then I'm all for it the
NBA is canceling their [ __ ] season I
think that's great maybe during this
time off they can figure out how they
sold their souls to the super team you
know maybe they can figure out when
their product got so [ __ ] boring that
they had to [ __ ] play music while it
was happening that anytime there was a
time out fifty people had to come out on
the court and [ __ ] start tumbling and
jumping on trampolines and dressed like
gorillas and dunk basketball like
whatever mascots whatever the [ __ ] is
going on at an NBA game
you know maybe they can figure out how
Instagram made every [ __ ] big man in
the NBA afraid to go up and challenge a
dunk running out of frame if the guy
comes down the lane and then all these
young people hey they put up highlight
films like what they just saw was was
[ __ ] incredible
there's no defense I'll tell you it's
never going to get to [ __ ]
coronavirus playing basketball with
another NBA player as James Harden if
you ever seen that guy attempt to play
defense deck he's not I bet that guy
hasn't had a cold in years
Jesus Christ I understand his game
though he's like my man's gonna [ __ ]
score 50 but I'm gonna score 52 that's
how that guy plays basketball
you know anyways but of course the NHL
hockey it's not canceled NHL hockey is
not canceled because fighting is legal
in the sport so they're not afraid of a
bad cold how about those Bruins they
beat the [ __ ] Flyers I missed the
game I gotta [ __ ] go back and watch
the damn thing and I finally figured out
why there was no MotoGP race at the top
level they had MotoGP three and two i
swatched MotoGP two it was also because
of the corona virus now I understand in
the Middle East why they're not [ __ ]
doing it you know they have like their
leaders over there are getting the
corona virus and that only means one
thing the leaders in the Middle East
they're out there walking amongst the
people they're not in the popemobile
they're not in a house painted white
that is aptly named the White House
everything out dumb it is that it's
called the White House the president
lives in the White House it's a house
it's white therefore the name is the
White House do you realize where you'd
be in the world if all throughout your
academic your scholastic career if
questions like that well I mean if the
questions of the universe were that
simple
where does the president live the
president lives in the White House why
is it called the White House because
it's a house and it is painted white
Johnnie is showing incredible skills in
class we really feel that he's going to
ascend to the top of a corporation okay
for all my flat earthers out there
please please please continue sending me
[ __ ] this is the most fascinating I love
watching these Flat Earth videos because
it lets me know what I sounded like 10
years ago
when I used to try to convince people of
my conspiracy theories which I still
think I'm right about nothing that I
have watched has even remotely convinced
me that there is a conspiracy to say
that the world is round so that NASA can
get a bunch of money to go to space
all right whether the earth is round or
flat eventually we would want to go to
space because that's how we are all
right because most men do not know how
to talk to women so what they have to
try to do is top one or another
professionally so if somebody flies at
30,000 feet someone's got to fly at
31,000 feet all right until they get all
the way up there whether it's [ __ ]
round or flat they would still go out to
space all right and then I also love
that because NASA wants to make money
and [ __ ] tax payers out of money that
they fake all these videos and then the
rest of the world goes along with it
countries with no space programs
countries that are not allies with those
countries that could easily come out and
debunk the whole thing and say not only
is the United States of America
polluting the earth at an alarming rate
they are also lying to their citizens
that the world is actually round simply
so they can [ __ ] them out of money I
mean do you realize the amount of money
that you have to spend and I mean I
can't even it's the dumbest [ __ ]
theory and then the fact that you're
listening to some [ __ ] idiot who's
not even a scientist telling you all of
this [ __ ]
I don't maybe he's a scientist I don't
[ __ ] know but he's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard in my life
is far and I'm not saying it's round I'm
not saying it's flat but the motivation
is the stupidest [ __ ] thing I've a
you don't need to tell people that the
world is round so you can get money to
go to outer space you don't even if it
was flat they're gonna they would have
been like we're gonna be the people that
are gonna colonize the underside of the
Flat Earth there's gravity on that side
too you know there's a whole other earth
on the other side that we're not using
and then they would just do that or do
flat-earthers do you believe that the
gravity is only on top that if you dug
far enough would you fall through the
bottom of the earth and then you would
be space traveling and then would people
throw a bunch of [ __ ] money at you
like you are a goddamn afternoon strip
you know listen you guys might be right
maybe the earth is flat I get it now
where they they have it like it's a
giant like pool a big round pool and you
just sort of swim around the edges of it
and that's how you go from [ __ ] you
know I guess la around the world around
the pool back to New York City I don't
know I can't I can't get enough of it I
love it please keep sending it to you I
want you guys to convince me that the
earth is flat I mean this is the thing
me let's say it is none of your stupid
[ __ ] theories as to why they would
waste all of this money that they're
[ __ ] us out of how does the whole
world get on on board with this we got
to help out America that we don't like
so that there's space program are we
given a cut of the money for the space
probe
Graham isn't the space program kind of
dead you know like the underwater cities
that we were going to at the bottom line
is you can't [ __ ] breathe the real
estate is is it's not worth any money is
it I don't know and I hope I sound just
as dumb to you as you sound to me I
[ __ ] I love it you know you know
listening to people talk about why the
earth is flat really makes me miss
drinking in the conversations I would
get into at the bar and how convinced
people were that time that [ __ ] guy
told me that missing airplane was
because it hit a Himalayan goose and the
goose went through the windshield of a
737 killed the pilot and then rekar
shade off like the magic bullet in the
JFK assassination knocked out the
copilot and that's how it crashed and
this person I swear to God as serious as
a heart attack presented that thing to
me unless he was the greatest actor of
all time I have no idea
I am I that that is probably what I miss
about drinking the most other than the
delicious taste is taste of alcohol is
the [ __ ] people that I met in the bar
and you know what I'm not looking down
on those people the Himalayan goose guy
because I was that guy I was that guy
one of my favorite times I was in a bar
and I was with an economic major and I
tried to tell him that the Federal
Reserve was not federal that it was a
private corporation and this [ __ ]
person lost their mind no it wasn't no
it isn't and they all laughed at me and
thought I was a dumb [ __ ] and I still
think I'm right about that but you know
something I have no way of proving it
cuz I don't know I wouldn't even know
where to look
cuz I too went on YouTube and watched a
bunch of videos I don't know what's
going on I have no [ __ ] idea
I do know I only think I know what's
going on is [ __ ] that I actually
experienced and what I experienced on
Tuesday night at the Dean Del Rey 40th
anniversary tribute of the passing of
Bon Scott was one of the great nights
I've had an entertainment man Dean Del
Rey has never sounded better singing he
absolutely
[ __ ] murdered all of those bonds got
songs and then they threw in a couple
classic they played overdose
they played soul stripper ac/dc never
even played that life it was [ __ ]
amazing and then the level of musicians
that I saw that night just how well
everybody was [ __ ] playing and all
the drummers I got to see who'd you get
to see pill oh you know guys like Steve
Gorman Brad Wilk Dave Lombardo was
[ __ ] amazing and even though for a
couple of songs probably the best I've
played when I've actually had to go out
and play live not saying I didn't still
[ __ ] have a couple of train wrecks on
some fills but I got back in there I had
a great great great [ __ ] time the
band sounded unbelievable and there's
this guy Phil I forget his last name an
Italian he has this YouTube channel
called solo Dallas and I used to [ __ ]
go on there and he would break down when
I was playing guitar I actually was
getting pretty decent at rhythm guitar
and he broke down every [ __ ] ac/dc
song and he broke it down right you know
there's so much [ __ ] out there that's
just [ __ ] wrong it'll give you the
basic core this guy had it down like
Angus is they're both playing the same
rhythm but Malcolm is is up here playing
the [ __ ] rhythm and Angus is down
here that's how they get that sound he
could break every [ __ ] note of every
goddamn solo down it was an amazing
channel than YouTube of course
copyrighted and [ __ ] and shut that
[ __ ] down but did that stop solo Dallas
no it did not he was so into ac/dc
that he literally built I don't know he
started a company he built amps that
sounded exactly like the ac/dc amps that
you can't [ __ ] buy anymore and then
ac/dc wore out their amps through
decades of melting people's faces with
their music and guess what they did they
went to this guy phil solo dallas and
they said now they use his
equipment he was there and he played on
[Music]
let there be rock and he played the
entire [ __ ] song note for note
it was [ __ ] on believe it sounded
like the record it was unreal it was on
Dave Lombardo just shooting the [ __ ] and
then he goes out there and plays like
you know he play don't let there be rock
like some of the fastest [ __ ] songs
and I was actually standing talking to
Steve Gorman going isn't it [ __ ]
unreal that he doesn't warm up he just
walks on it can play at that tempo and
Steve just laughed he goes this is like
a [ __ ] ballad for this guy and then I
finally got to see Brad we'll play live
on dirty deeds that was amazing
it's just the whole [ __ ] thing was
just it was awesome it was awesome I had
some friends come out that absolutely
love [ __ ] ac/dc and and they they
just say I don't they everybody was just
like I can't [ __ ] believe how good
that was my favorite thing Juliette
Lewis playing singing the [ __ ] dirty
deeds who's one of the best actresses
out there
actors whatever the [ __ ] he's supposed
to say and the reality is is she's
that's actually her hobby I think if you
actually watch her sing with the band
she's actually really a rockstar who
kind of moonlights as an actor anyways
it was a [ __ ] incredible night it was
just a [ __ ] incredible night and
there's rumor that that's the last time
Dean's gonna do it I hope that's not
[ __ ] true but it was it was [ __ ]
amazing and I got to tell you one of if
you have if you play drums okay if you
like me and for 20 years you played
inside by yourself you're really missing
out on if you ever get to play out live
with drums that are miked up it's just
[ __ ] unbelievable
is such a different experience it's so
much [ __ ] fun in another life in
another life I don't even care where I
would have got in it I would have done
that that's how much [ __ ] fun it is
but granted I'm also just dropping in
for one night to do my hobby live in
front of people where you know there's
all that other [ __ ] with being a
professional musician having to ride in
fans with three four or five other
[ __ ] people deal with everybody's
[ __ ] personality get [ __ ] over by
the music business have a hit and then
have to play that song for the rest of
your [ __ ] life
I understand there's the other side of
it but as far as where I'm from
old dad band here it's pretty [ __ ]
awesome anyways let me read a little uh
advertising here what do we got here
Oh simply safe simply safe with home
security there's two ways you can go
about protecting your home there's their
traditional way getting a shotgun saying
I don't know you repeat I do not know
you you know the [ __ ] mailman who's
subbing in for some guy you know you
know you're used to seeing the
traditional way where you wait weeks for
a technician to do a messy installation
that costs a small fortune or there's
the other way simply safe simply safe is
everything you need in a home security
system it's a no it's award-winning
protection two-time winner of C net
Editors Choice Award Sibley safe
blankets your whole home in safety and
who doesn't want safety during this
difficult time people gonna lose their
minds I think they get no NBA no bread
and circus you can't go outside III
can't find hand sanitizer would it be
great if simply safe made you feel safe
in your home you get comprehend
comprehensive protection for your entire
home how many times I've said that word
comprehensive and I have no idea what
the [ __ ] does that word mean that's a
great [ __ ] word go [ __ ] yourself
comprehensive comprehensive death
definition comprehensive including all
or nearly all elements or aspects of
something this guy was a comprehensive
[ __ ] bill could you use it in a
sentence all right where am I here you
get comprehensive protection for your
entire home isn't that redundant now why
would you say entire home if
comprehensive means complete including
all or nearly all elements and aspects
of something you get comprehensive
protection for your home you get
comprehensive protection for your entire
home they put an entire in there for all
the [ __ ] idiots like me you didn't
know what comprehensive meant
I don't know how comprehensive meant
means but you get it for your entire
home not just half of it outdoor cameras
and doorbells are alerting you well
that's where doorbells are they are
outside why would a doorbell be inside
it's like one of those horror movies
where the guy calls you up and you find
out he's calling you from inside your
house where did that doorbell come from
is he at the front door oh my god it's
ring from in the house comprehensively
doorbells alert you to anyone
approaching your home entry motion and
glass break sensors guard inside you
barely notice it's there but what's true
what's truly remarkable is you can set
up all of this system by yourself anyone
can do it it takes 30 minutes to an hour
tops and there's absolutely no
trade-offs to your safety you'll have an
army of highly trained security experts
ready to dispatch police to your home
and a moment's notice 24/7 and it's only
50 cents a day with no contracts it's
why the verge calls simply safe the best
home security system go to simply
safecom slash bird today and you'll get
free shipping and a 60 day risk-free
trial you got nothing to lose go now and
be sure you go to simply safe dot-com /
bird that simply safe dot-com / BRR
alright there you go
here's a couple of things I forgot to
read the other day when I was I was on
with Dean del Rey all right fan roadtrip
hey Bill greetings from Copenhagen oh my
god Copenhagen Denmark lovely city I did
have one hell of a [ __ ] for a cabdriver
he trashed my country because you
Americans are so stupid and I was like
oh yes if you're so smart how come he
driving a [ __ ] cab
I'm usually polite in that [ __ ]
country but I felt good trash in that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right after a lot of conflict with
my girlfriend I managed to get a
once-in-a-lifetime trip to the US with
my life buddies won't elaborate I made
it happen this April yeah who the [ __ ]
is she today if what if she wanted to go
on a girls trip
to [ __ ] Morocco you're gonna tell us
she can't go you know trust me if that
what you say you think I'm gonna blow a
camel if that were this relationship is
right but you want to go with your
buddies this is the thing women no guys
are dumb and we'll stick our peepees and
anything that looks like a [ __ ] hole
so she's probably right we are all we
are we are three guys one pasty redhead
as yourself one white privileged as it
is nowadays and a black Moses look-alike
of a young at Isaac Hayes Jesus Christ
this seems like this is another Netflix
series all right we are all fans and we
were there at your show in Copenhagen oh
that's great thank you for coming out
it's a tradition to do a road trip once
a year but nowadays and while things get
serious with our girlfriends we decided
to go all in and do a 22 day trip to the
States before this fun part of life ends
that's smart this is a movie I know you
never give recommendations but as you
toured these places I need your top
recommendations for the below five
cities it can be a bar slash place titty
bar whatever why would you say titty bar
I didn't know you're gonna say that I
wouldn't have read that what if your
girlfriend listens to this how many
[ __ ]
guys from three guys from [ __ ]
Denmark from Copenhagen that are going
to the United States include a redhead a
white dude and a black Moses look-alike
of a young Isaac Hayes alright that's
your fault for [ __ ] doing that
alright note that our drink tolerance is
very high all right LA where would you
go to in LA oh god I'm a married guy in
LA I don't I don't know what to tell you
I don't booze anymore what's a good bar
think think about what you're trying to
do to me well think all right let's go
to New Orleans the governor's palace dos
dos jefes it's a great place to just
[ __ ] smoke a cigar and have a drink
listen to some local music oh and
there's a [ __ ] place you know there's
a place they try to tell you you know
those beignet doughnuts there's a place
that everybody goes to and then there's
another place right down the [ __ ]
Street that nobody goes to what the [ __ ]
is the word I'm not gonna remember Las
Vegas where would you go to in Las Vegas
Tijuana oh my god no I don't know I I'm
sorry wait I could do LA all right where
would I go to in LA I don't know go to
Bill's burgers and Sherman Oaks I like
that place there's a place the corner
cottage in Burbank as a great breakfast
burrito
wait a [ __ ] would you go to drink come
on there was a place I used to like it
was called the seven grand it was a
whit's a whiskey bar you know I went
there on New Year's Eve and there was
nobody there it was brand-new and then I
came back like six months later and I
could smell puke in the [ __ ] Lobby
and I went upstairs and was packed but I
think you know the [ __ ]
this point is probably leveled off but I
really enjoyed that place if you want to
get a cigar I like Hollywood smoke
there's a place Cuban seed that's
tremendous there's a place v-cut I like
all of those places come on oh there's a
place Howard's famous burgers the fries
are okay but the burger is [ __ ] great
is another place has a good brunch
Downtown LA's called the little easy
it's a New Orleans base place instead of
the Big Easy cuz it's not in the Big
Easy it's in LA they call it a little
easy and then if you want to go on a
hike I go to the [ __ ] Griffith Park
or [ __ ] Runyon Canyon what else wow
this sucks this is like when somebody
asks you you know remember back in the
ad gonna do when you had to go to a
music store to buy music yeah during the
week you were thinking all of this [ __ ]
you wanted to buy then you go and then
you couldn't [ __ ] remember I'm sorry
that's like the most I can remember as
far as bars I mean poses booze if you
want to go to legendary places the
frolic room Hollywood Boulevard
what was that another one I used to go
to it was one on Argyle I used to go to
I liked holes in the wall though you
know I don't know as far as titty bars I
have no [ __ ] idea I've met at a titty
bar in forever I guess the famous one
out here is Jumbo's clown room but if
everybody always went there for the
wrong [ __ ] reasons I actually the
last time I went there I went there with
my wife my laughs because she wanted to
go she wanted to see what the [ __ ]
deal was and we went in there we
actually saw a stripper quit on stage so
there you go there's that all right
overrated underrated she quit cuz nobody
was paying attention there was barely
anybody in there and she was like why
should I keep dancing and at one point I
don't know where she took her cell phone
out from
she was laying on her stomach checking
her [ __ ] email and a waitress walked
by saw it laughed and said that's
[ __ ] awesome
alright overrated underrated underrated
anthrax the band oh yeah that [ __ ]
amazing overrated I guess some people
don't know that that right overrated
unsolicited advice about how to dress I
work with the younger woman who always
tells me what I should be wearing and
tells me why I'm single based on things
like this well I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say she wants to [ __ ] you which
is funny because she's kind of fat and I
really want to tell her what she should
be eating well let me tell you I think
that that that [ __ ] ficky there wants
to take a ride on your schmeckle how
many hundred calorie bags of snack can
someone eat before you tell them they're
lying to themselves yeah well you know
what are you gonna do you know she's
trying to I mean listen rather than take
it negatively why don't you just go
there and take the sloppy bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] well this is why this is why you
can't do that because then you have to
go back to work alright then old fatty
cakes think she like her now and then
what are you supposed to do you know you
know what you do you get us some sharise
berries listen a great way to go in life
it's took taking me half a century to
figure this out is to not argue with
people and to go with empathy alright
she has she has an issue with food
alright she's trying but you're a
[ __ ] truck that's just like the
[ __ ] guy has left the thing in
Reverse for like [ __ ] ten minutes
they're obviously not backing up anymore
it's like the rest of the world doesn't
need to know you're in Reverse can you
just stick it in [ __ ] Park until
whatever is in the [ __ ] way is out of
the way and then put it in reverse you
can't huh your cement [ __ ] truck
driving country
um yeah it's probably her weird way of
flirting with you you know I don't know
it's a very easy thing to shut off she
tells you you're late yeah that you
[ __ ] dress weird just lie and tell
her you got laid last weekend well I get
laid wearing this exact [ __ ] outfit
huh you want to smell my finger and then
you know she'll [ __ ] be turned off by
you probably won't want to eat you know
thinking of smelling a [ __ ] two day
old [ __ ] on your finger right then
she'll lay off the hundred hundred
calorie bags there you go I problems
with one [ __ ] sentence maybe it
wasn't one sentence maybe the earth is
flat I don't [ __ ] know but please
keep sending me those video people
there's nothing wrong with the
conspiracy conspiracy theory is actually
a healthy way of thinking of the world
because you're at least smart enough to
realize that a lot of times people who
are supposed to have your best interest
in any--in you don't okay and I'm not
talking about the government man I'm
talking about that person that you sleep
in next to what's going on with them oh
no I don't introduce that into your
[ __ ] personal life all right that is
the podcast all right stay safe
everybody take your vitamin C wash your
[ __ ] hands okay stop touching your
face listen to the government I never
say that but yeah if they tell you to
[ __ ] stay inside not go to a [ __ ]
NBA game yeah why don't you just do that
for a couple of [ __ ] weeks you know
here's another thing too these [ __ ]
people will go I can't take two weeks
off from work I'll be [ __ ] destitute
I have a lot of empathy for people who
are [ __ ] broke all right but if you
are college educated you're hot and
you're in your 40s okay if you can't
take two weeks off and there's no major
health issues or anything you don't have
ten [ __ ] kids all right if you're hot
and you [ __ ] have a college degree
and you've been working for your entire
adult life and you're in your 40s and
you can't take two weeks off without the
whole thing
falling apart I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say you [ __ ] suck it money you're
not good with money you need to take a
money while you're while you're
quarantined why don't you learn and
watch one of your 52 flatscreen [ __ ]
TVs in your house that you didn't
[ __ ] need just sit down in your room
of [ __ ] and look where your money went
and just really look at [ __ ] and be like
why I'm doing it right now why did I buy
that why did I allow my wife to buy that
easy you're not allowed to hit him
anymore this has been the money if
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcasts enjoy the music
picked out by the wonderful Andrew
families who by the way is a hell of a
musician himself you ever seen him play
guitar follow him on Instagram he's got
some music here and then we have a bonus
episode of the Thursday of a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast from I don't know a few
years ago it's usually how he does it
all right god bless you I hope you don't
get a fever and all you guys who can't
watch the NBA come on over to where I'm
at watch the [ __ ] NHL watch those
Edmonton Oilers watch those [ __ ]
Colorado Avalanche my Boston Bruins
watch the st. Louis Blues it's a lot of
great hawk the Flyers a fun team to
watch a lot of fun the Pittsburgh
Penguins going to put it back together
when a Peck Jets are fun to watch
there's a lot of fun teams well come on
over listen to a couple of national
anthems not one you get an extra
national anthem when you watch a lot of
the hockey all right go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend okay stay safe and
God bless you net thoughts and prayers
support the troops
it's the Monday morning podcast and 12
hey what's going on it's bill burr sorry
I was just watching a lot of sports this
weekend and when you watch a lot of
sports you're gonna hear that song over
and over again oh my god what is that
song who wrote that god it's in my head
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
March 12th 2012 and just to give you a
heads up we're about a month and three
days away before you have to give all
those [ __ ] you money right that's just
gonna go to the bank of [ __ ] that
nobody ever talks about they don't talk
about it do they they went after Roger
Clemens harder than they went after
anybody at AIG you realize that did you
or did you not shoot steroids in your
ass so you could throw the ball past
that [ __ ] guy about the Hall of Fame
yeah I know more about that than I ain't
know anybody else have I don't have any
AIG uh banker cards why don't I have
some of those then you could tell me
which one of them were the [ __ ]
cheaters um so how'd you guys do it this
year did you have the money taken out
early so then you can get it back at the
end of the year huh is that what you did
do that's what I do I have I have like
all the taxes taken out and then in the
end I get money back because I'm too
[ __ ] irresponsible to take my money
upfront cuz I know I'm gonna blow it
right so what I do is I give the
government an interest-free loan all
year that's that's my game plan in life
people have zero exempts okay or
whatever the [ __ ] it is have the least
amount of taxes taken out all right just
don't blow all your money at least you
can keep it in the [ __ ] bank and
they'll give you a couple extra [ __ ]
quarters for it why give an
interest-free loan I know why cuz you're
young you're young you want to go out
get some [ __ ] in a 12-pack I hear you
Keystone white
um this is the money morning podcast
from Monday March 12 2012 I believe I
said it a couple of times I don't know
why I feel like I have to keep
reiterating um a lot of [ __ ] to talk
about this week you know I was on
vacation I didn't do [ __ ]
I probably put on ice five pounds you
know had a great breakfast burrito
yesterday about in Glendale California
had a phenomenal breakfast burrito a
place that I had been hearing about and
I kept asking the lovely Nia to go but
you know as life would have it we were
always too busy right so she was doing a
bunch of [ __ ] yesterday with their
friends and by [ __ ] I mean shooting
a short film not [ __ ] but so you
know she's shooting it here at the
homestead so I you know I'm gonna get
the [ __ ] out of here
so called up a buddy of mine we went
over there you know couple of getting a
[ __ ] burrito went over there we had a
great time so on the way back I come you
know I dropped my buddy off or whatever
and I I mentioned to Nia in between
shots and said hey you know I finally
checked out that breakfast burrito place
it was [ __ ] delicious you gotta go
with the steak burrito and she did the
classic woman thing we've been [ __ ]
planning it for six months all right yes
I went over I was hungry I wanted one I
did I did something fun without you yes
I did alright what cuz I'm in a
relationship I'm only allowed to have
fun when I'm with you at some point I
have to break off right even the monkeys
do that you know they hang out with the
tribe and every once in a while you go
off in the bush you rub one out
it's what the chips do so anyways what
what happened this week Peyton Manning
maque Sanchez right that's what
everybody's been talking about I think I
think everybody made the right move you
know I think the Colts made the right
move what what are they supposed to do
they're supposed to hang on to Peyton
Manning
a 36 year old guy he's had four NEX
operations this is the second time his
neck got fused do you think it's gonna
get better do you think that it keeps
going up from here and I know what you
cold fans are saying you're right he is
and he's the [ __ ] all right but he's 36
[ __ ] years old all right this is what
sucks about sports and what's great
about comedy you know what's great about
comedy is I am seven years older than
that [ __ ] fused Frankenstein
[ __ ]
but I can continue to do stand-up he
can't I mean he can't continue to do
what he loves
well he can't but you know I'm saying
and a couple years he won't be able to
so what I'm saying is you got this
Andrew Luck kid and I know he's not
gonna be Peyton Manning I'm not saying
that all right but the Colts just like
the Patriots at some point your guy is
gonna retire and that is gonna be a long
40 story fall and [ __ ] you're gonna
splat on the ground or you can rip the
band-aid off get rid of the dude and
maybe hit one of those little canapé
things with an Andrew Luck before you
[ __ ] hit the sidewalk all right I
think I think they did the right thing I
think it took a lot of bulls and I don't
know for entire year there wasn't a
doctor on the planet that would clear
Peyton to play and then all of a sudden
right before he's due to sign this this
big 29 million dollar thing he finds two
guys who go guess what I'm a-okay
I think at that point the Colts had
already made the decision and they were
moving on so I don't know I think it was
a ballsy move on their part and I think
in the short run they'll look like
morons but in the long run I think it
was a smart move because the Colts in 15
20 30 years are still gonna be a
franchise and 15 20 30 [ __ ] years
Peyton Manning is gonna be like 50 60
years old I can't do the math 51 you
know what are you gonna do you got to
choose the franchise so and then the
Mark Sanchez thing I think was great
they signed the guy it gives it gives
Sanchez
a boost like hey these guys believe in
me but then they also got this backdoor
thing where hey if you suck after next
not this season but next season we can
walk and we don't know you're the other
half of the contract hey we gave it a
shot go [ __ ] yourself so that's what I
think that is my belief and Paul virzi
Paul virzi thinks that the Colts are the
dumbest [ __ ] ever and that Peyton
Manning is gonna throw for nine million
yards like he does every season for some
other team and then lose in the first
round of the playoffs I mean if I was
Peyton Manning I would try to go to the
49ers that's where I would try to go
even though they're not courting them I
would I would be like listen give me a
pay a play [ __ ] contract that's where
I want to go I want to be protected so
we don't have protection issues and I
want to [ __ ] an awesome defense and a
great [ __ ] code that would be perfect
be [ __ ] perfect but instead where is
he gonna go where's he gonna go you
think he's gonna go back to Tennessee I
still got a lot of friends down there
all right go to the old Tennessee Titans
all right who gives a [ __ ] I just
realized halfway through that [ __ ]
whole thing I was so goddamn sick
talking about it you know so I apologize
let's talk about the one thing that
everybody showed me they're so [ __ ]
weak was everybody's like you got to
check out this kony2012
it's about this dictator in Uganda who's
you know got the boy soldiers over there
and he's just all these war crimes and
everything so I call right I got a
bleeding heart I'll watch this [ __ ] and
I got to tell you something I got about
five minutes into that video and found
the guy who made the documentary so
[ __ ] self-serving and annoying I had
to shut it off at that point when when
the when the Ugandan kid is crying
because he saw his brother get killed in
front of him I mean it was unbuttoned
then immediately he just cuts to now I'm
gonna sit down with my son and tell him
it's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
the hope the whole thing is supposed to
be about these Ugandan kids and this
[ __ ] guy starts the video off with
his wife giving birth to his son it
takes you like three minutes before you
even in Uganda I'm sitting it like I
thought is a documentary he you know
what he did he did something like that
big fat flounder there what the [ __ ]
his name the guy there who tried to make
Canada look like a utopia who's a guy
there who never shaves and always has on
a dirty bald cap because he's just like
us he's the working man what's his name
huh Bowling for Columbine guy he does
the same thing where he inserts himself
into the documentary and just makes him
look like he's the [ __ ] you know
I don't know the goddamn grand pooh-bah
who has the whole [ __ ] world figured
out this guy did the exact same thing
and annoyed the [ __ ] out of me didn't
change obviously how I feel about that
warlord or any of the boy soldiers
things but I mean it didn't teach me
anything I didn't [ __ ] already know
there was a rapper who came out who was
actually a former Boy soldier and I read
this whole thing about him and he was
saying like all these gangster rappers
who he sit here and brag about killing
somebody he goes goes that's not the way
it is he goes if you take a life you
don't brag he goes it haunts you it
haunts you for the rest of your life
something like that was just like wow I
can't wait to hear this this guy rap and
then he stunk
it's [ __ ] one of the big tragedies he
had the actual stories he had the life
experience he had the pain and he just
he couldn't rap it was very unfortunate
yeah it's kind of like me I mean I'm on
an amazing guy I'm a good-looking guy
and you know I just can't go to the
beach so that's why when you go to the
Jersey Shore there's all those morons
out there because you know everybody
gets a gift you know and if you can tan
one of the sacrifices is you don't get a
personality in life you know so then you
go down on the beach and then that's all
there is down there
volleyball right that's all that's going
on down there and meanwhile absolute
Saints like myself have to sit in the
the basement or the bottom floor of a
dilapidated house that needs a new
[ __ ] roof evidently I got I want to
[ __ ] I want to go down to Home Depot
and I want to buy a hatchet and I want
to chop down my [ __ ] garage
it's [ __ ] goddamn thing it's made for
a Model T okay and if you don't know if
you notice the old cars
I mean whaled ruled that that kind of
old is they were skinny you sat inside
the [ __ ] wheel wells like the tires
you know you know what I mean you know I
went by inside the wheel wells you know
I'm saying like you sat
shoulder-to-shoulder hey let me take out
mache let's go down to the market and go
get some flour right you'd be sitting
shoulder-to-shoulder with another guy
both of you were probably what like five
three two five six and wait a hundred
forty pounds why I oughta
right and you sat right next to each
other and then the fenders flared out
and the [ __ ] wheels were wider that's
I'm saying the you said like you know
what the [ __ ] I'm saying oh and by the
way [ __ ] all you guys who think I'm a
[ __ ] cuz I don't understand how planes
fly alright we only figured out how to
do it in the last hundred years so
you're telling me everybody before that
was a [ __ ] idiot right that George
Washington Carver who came up with
peanut butter and realized tomatoes
weren't poisonous you know he didn't
[ __ ] ought to get off the ground
did he you're telling me a lie whitney
with the cotton gin I didn't see him
flying around alright I have a very poor
science background and I [ __ ] really
sat there and tried to understand the
amount of [ __ ] that I actually learned
this week really sitting there trying to
read up on how a plane stays up I mean I
had to go back to like the Fountain of
Youth of science like everything was
just like well air pressure I'm like
what is air pressure
I don't you understand I don't even get
it you know and I actually watched some
interesting
experiments one were a guy held a flame
underneath a coke can and he heated up
the [ __ ] air which caused it to
expand right thus less air was taking up
more space or some [ __ ] and then he
dunked it in some cold water and then
immediately the [ __ ] can crushed and
I had to watch that experiment three
times to understand what the [ __ ] was
going on that basically he cooled off
the air inside which caused a vacuum and
before the air could rush into the can
the pressure from the [ __ ] air on the
outside crushed the can see that I
didn't know that last week and you guys
are awful [ __ ] people you know and
when you have dumb kids someday that's
how you're gonna handle them
you're gonna keep gonna you're gonna say
all those mean things that you said
about me that me a [ __ ] Saint who
comes on every week and does a free
goddamn podcast that has nothing but
positivity for all groups especially
women you know you guys need to sit down
and take a long [ __ ] look at
yourselves cuz I got to tell you
something right now I was really
disappointed in a lot of you you know I
did the other day I was walking my dog
right buh doo doo doo doo and we went
around a corner oh dude and I was so
[ __ ] tired you know I went to grab
the headphones these [ __ ] headphones
that I use when I do the podcast and
they're already big enough all right and
I already looks stupid I look like a
[ __ ] you know person who's trying to
get attention but the reality is is I'm
just too lazy to go to Best Buy I see it
I'm driving by and it's like I know I
need headphones I have the money to get
headphones but just the thought of
pulling into the parking lot trying to
find a [ __ ] parking spot getting
behind that person who's waiting for
that person who's you think's gonna
leave and then isn't leaving going into
the [ __ ] store trying to [ __ ] find
it and having that douche in the blue
shirt oh you want to get a flat-screen
no I don't I want some headphones oh I'm
not in the headphones department man I
don't know where that is I didn't want
to deal with it so anyways so I [ __ ]
came down here half-asleep my dogs going
crazy right wants to go outside whenever
it sees me get up it goes nuts because
it knows what's gonna happen we're going
on this [ __ ] awesome hike so I ended
up grabbed and I grabbed these vic firth
headphones which are for drumming which
you can wear and it they like block out
the sound of you know how loud drums are
and I got to take a picture of them with
with them on my head how [ __ ] stupid
I look I was wondering why they seem so
heavy I was half asleep walking down the
street and I saw my shadow on the ground
they look like those you know those old
guys who go to baseball games and they
have like the antenna and that keeping
score they're like twice as big as those
[ __ ] things and I look like an
[ __ ] and I know everybody driving by
I thought I was being doing that hipster
thing where I was like deliberately
dressing like a douche just to get
attention to be like well no these are
from 1974 what year is this I wasn't I
was actually embarrassed and then I was
gonna take him off and then I was like
wait a minute
that's even worse it was legitimate [ __ ]
up and now you're gonna take him off
because you're worried what people are
doing as they drive by you you know cuz
they're gonna make a comment as they
drive by Bill and then what after they
drive by you they get on with their
[ __ ] lives what is wrong with you so
I left them on and that's that story oh
it's been a slow week when you're on
vacation he doesn't have anything to
talk about all right let's get to let's
get some advertising for this week all
right and [ __ ] you too anybody who
doesn't like this
alright that's why the podcast is free
all right stamps calm everybody I've
been telling you about this for weeks
alright and this has been one of the
very successful ad campaigns here on the
Monday morning podcast oh let's do it
again everybody you guys can probably do
this one word-for-word with me do you
like go on to the part even podcast do
you like owner of the post office no do
you like standing behind old people
sending cookies that are already stale
two grandsons who aren't going to
them no do you like standing behind
somebody who's putting together 12 boxes
as they slowly inched their little
Caravan forward as all you want to do is
just stand there and try and buy some
stamps of course you don't
would it be wonderful if you could
handle all of that stuff in your own
home at any hour of the night clothed or
unclothed wouldn't that be amazing well
thank God for stamps calm all you need
is a computer and a printer and you can
use stamps calm whenever you need it
however you want to do it all right you
be watching Goodfellas and printing out
stamps all at the same time naked while
eating a coffee cake however you want to
do it people
this still is America the post office
may be closed but stamps calm is always
open all right here's the endorsement
take it from me pointing at my chest
with my thumb you can do everything you
can do at the post office with stamps
calm yeah you can do everything except
go on a shooting spree you can do that
in your house but you can just gonna
kill people you love I'm special offer
right now stamps calm has a special
offer enough from my listeners pointing
at my chest once again use my last name
Barbie you are are for a no risk trial
you get a hundred and ten dollar bonus
off offer that includes a digital scale
and fifty-five dollars of free post-its
the digital scale is my favorite thing I
send out all my DVDs using that every
once in a while they put me in a bear
hug and I tell it I'm gonna wear and I
make her sit on it and she giggles and
then we have a fun time after that
oh here's the call to action don't wait
act now go to stamps calm before you do
anything else I don't click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and you type in Barbie URR that
stamps.com
enter Barbie you are our 110 dollar
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and $55 a free postage okay I
don't know what else you guys need for
me you know probably a little more funny
I've been hooking you guys up with
everything even listen because of this
podcast you don't have to go to the post
office anymore because of this podcast
if you play pick-up hockey you don't
have to get slammed
foot with the puck anymore do you why
because escape vendor calm skate friend
er you got to use these I actually last
week for the first time I played in a
game and I got to tell you I had not
played I had not played a hockey on the
ice or ice hockey as some people call it
I had not played a hockey and since
January because I was afraid Murphy's
Law that uh if I was gonna get hurt it
was gonna be right before my special so
I was a healthy scratch for the last
like six weeks and I finally played and
I didn't even notice that I had him on
and I actually was actually a couple of
people I played with oh yeah I want to
get those and blah blah blah blah blah I
was psyched I thought they were gonna
call me a [ __ ] for wearing them but
they didn't but anyways if you go to
skate fender calm and use a promotional
code bill burr all lowercase you get
five dollars off of them and it's a
great thing you know do you like your
feet sure if we all do wouldn't it be
nice to not take a puck at 80 85 miles
an hour to the side of your foot when
you have to go in and make a big
presentation the next day I mean it's
all up to you people if you want to have
to put on a loafer that you have to have
a custom zipper up the side because you
wanted to be some shot-blocking douche
without any protection that's up to you
alright but if you really love your feet
and your children you'll get you'll get
some skate fenders and until then until
you do I don't want you even talking to
me um alright to hell am I doing here
let's get back to the podcast here uh-oh
somebody said bill where do you think
Peyton Manning is going to play I have
no idea my gut would say he wants to go
back to Tennessee just a good ol boy
never meanin no harm got a rectangle
head and a funny way of talking why's
his forehead so big I think he's their
forehead you know I have a big forehead
they have like a swollen forehead
I think Archie every time Eli and Peyton
made a bad pass or did made a mental
error in the backyard
he can't took off his belt you know had
the buckle in his hand let's be fair and
he is walk right in the front of the
[ __ ] forehead and then they will dad
I gotta put some ice on it and he goes
you're not putting ice on that do you
make that throw 20 more times then the
Sun would go down and by the time they
put ice on it didn't matter that's why
their heads are just like that to this
day that's all true people I don't know
what else to tell you oh my god is this
gonna be one of these podcasts I really
I can't do podcasts when I [ __ ] I'm
on vacation because I don't do anything
you know I was watching the the Bruins
lose to the Penguins yesterday I watched
the Celtics lose to the Lakers I gotta
tell you this right now Danny Ainge you
know I don't think I don't I don't like
what he's doing I just don't like what
he's doing with the team I think he got
lucky
I think Kevin McHale hooked him up but
as each year goes by and the Celtics
somehow keep getting older every time I
see them they're older every year goes
by every trade deadline somehow not only
do we not get younger not only do we not
stay the same we get [ __ ] older I
told you ever see so many knee pad elbow
pads and those stretchy sleeves in your
life I don't know I think Danny Ainge is
white Isiah he just got lucky you know
he got he got that one ring so now no
one's gonna like question I'm kind of
like Peyton Manning you know he got that
one ring and then all of a sudden
everybody ignores it you know he puts up
nine million yards in the in the during
the regular season and then loses in the
first round of the playoffs every
goddamn year you don't I mean that's
what I'm talking about
yeah I just I don't get it the Bruins
I'm not worried about Bruins were you
know I don't know I've had some injuries
and that type of stuff but what I love
about them and the Celtics is they don't
quit and I thought we wouldn't get
killed by the Lakers yesterday I don't
know and I missed actually missed the
first two periods of the Bruins game
because I had the center ice package and
I put it on and I couldn't find the game
and I was like am I out of my mind I
thought they were playing today and I
didn't realize it was at the NBC game so
then I went out on my mandate and I got
a breakfast burrito and then I got I got
a text message
from a Pittsburgh Penguins fan going you
watching this game which I know what
that means it means are you watching us
kick your ass because you know if we
were up for two one
I wouldn't got a text would I Billy
Gardell huh look at me dropping a name
um anyways I don't know I think the
broom is gonna be okay but the Celtics
see as long as the Lakers don't win as
long as the Lakers don't win and then
continue to claim that none they'll say
they have 17 championships as long as I
don't have to endure that I don't know
but it's it's inevitable it's inevitable
the Lakers are gonna win what they
consider their 17th which is really
their 16th NBA championship before the
Celtics get their 18th just because
they're just a better franchise there
are better franchise and people want to
go play from Dwight Howard is is like
dying to play for him you know what
kills me about that cuz he wants to
focus on his movie career who wants to
see a [ __ ] 7-foot love interest you
know what I mean but you can be an
action hero with your [ __ ] head
coming out of the sunroof of the car
maybe you've seven feet [ __ ] tall
wait for him to do another Conan the
Barbarian movie and you can fly in from
Orlando during the off-season and do it
then focus on your movie career why
don't you focus on having some sort of
[ __ ] baseline move if you had one of
those you could already had a ring
instead of letting Pau Gasol eat you up
[ __ ] guy is made out of he's like a I
don't what to his his mom breeded was it
a squirrel I thought that was a fox
I don't like squirrels I know a lot of
people like squirrels cuz they water-ski
on the news but I'm not one of those
guys all right they don't fool me with
their [ __ ] they're cute rats
fuzzy tail um I don't like not a big fan
of the squirrels I don't I don't like I
don't like things with creepy little
[ __ ] hands I don't like raccoons
I don't like God I don't like squirrels
I don't like him
I don't like how they sit up meeting
they said sit there staring at you like
they're sizing you up or something you
know anyway you got a [ __ ] problem
yeah then they stopped chewing and just
sort of stare at you yeah you you
[ __ ] looking at me I'm sitting here
you [ __ ] looking at me you know and
then you make a step and then they do
that you know a little [ __ ] I'm gonna
run and then they [ __ ] take off that
[ __ ] you know instigators squirrels
are instigators and I don't appreciate
them and that's all I have to say about
that
this is just one of these start stop
start stop [ __ ] podcasts dental
hygiene a build oh Jesus I wanted some
advice on dental hygiene I listen to and
I listen to an older product at an older
episode of the podcast you were talking
about how you were a dental assistant
and talking about people's teeth I brush
I brush every day in the morning and use
an electric toothbrush but is that
enough I noticed that it's harder to
brush the backs of my my backs my the
backs of my teeth and there you go way
to proofread than the front do you have
a routine what are the secrets to having
good tea I understood this oh my oh my
[ __ ] time in a dental office I never
understood why people had such [ __ ]
difficulty brushing their goddamn teeth
do I have any tips yeah brush him in the
morning and brush him at night before
you go to bed use floss electric
toothbrush is great because you know if
you brush too hard you're gonna brush
away some in some of your gum line and
that could lead to some sort of
periodontal disease look at me huh
doesn't understand flight I understand
this [ __ ] so and if you don't want to
use an electric toothbrush then I
suggest you use one of those soft
bristled ones if you brush really had
but uh yeah
you [ __ ] go twice a day and then you
floss every day and then you [ __ ] get
your teeth cleaned every six months if
you do that you should be fine unless
you're just genetically compromised and
you just have bad teeth at which point
you shouldn't get upset what you should
do is rejoice that you live in this era
where you can be that weak of a human
being and part of this species and still
somehow survive and be allowed to
continue breeding because Nature doesn't
like people like you Nature doesn't like
people like you who are weak in the
teeth toofus area all right back in the
day all your teeth would have fell out
and you wouldn't have been able to eat
and then you would have gradually
starved to death and you know what no
one would have cared because they would
have been in their little wigwam under
40 blankets because it was cold outside
and that's why the water was fresh and
the air was clean back then all right it
has nothing to do with the Industrial
Revolution it has to do with the fact
that people with weak teeth are allowed
to continue living all right and until
we [ __ ] sit down and just address the
fact that weak people should not survive
we are going to get weaker as a species
you know and I'm including myself I
shouldn't be here
the amount of time somebody has tried to
explain to me how a [ __ ] airplane
gets off the ground like what am i
contributing I gotta be honest with you
people I've done the whole [ __ ] I
went down the rabbit hole
I read all that conspiracy theory and
all that [ __ ] and I was like these
[ __ ] bankers these
[ __ ] Illuminati and all this
[ __ ] and at the end of the day now
that I've traveled and I've met all
these different [ __ ] people I get it
I understand the Illuminati I understand
why they want to go down to five hundred
thousand people five hundred million
people you can't [ __ ] have too many
people the world is uh can't sustain it
and most people are [ __ ] so if you
have 500 million you know that basically
means you and all your friends are going
to survive and then you'll have plenty
of people to
sweep up the driveway and beyond that
what else do you need
you know I challenge you go into a
Walmart and find a soul worth saving I
get it like I totally understand the
Illuminati and they're the best of the
best
they're running [ __ ] and one day they're
gonna bring the hammer down and there's
not a [ __ ] thing you can do about it
but you know what you know what's cool
is and when they kill you is you get to
go on to the next [ __ ] you know which is
either nothing or something right
what do you think happens when you die
you know what I think it is you ever
meditate and you get like that tingly
feeling and you just start floating like
right up out your body you ever do that
[ __ ] I think that's what it is
you just floating around all tingly you
know levitating above [ __ ] it doesn't
even make sense does it what forever
what the [ __ ] you gonna do forever and
then you go to heaven forever really
name name something you want to do
forever you know other than obvious [ __ ]
like be healthy and that type of stuff I
mean they wouldn't get boring after a
while
wouldn't you then like you know take
little trips down to hell like you're
going to Tijuana you know for the
weekend go down there you know get a
couple of lap dances from all those
[ __ ] that God didn't want to save all
right and then go back up to heaven once
you have to do something at some point
can you just imagine like don't you hate
when you go to church and everybody's
all [ __ ] happy and smiley and saying
how blessed they are and behind him you
go you dude you're jerking off to porn
you see it you know it you know there's
that other side it's the balance the
yang and the [ __ ] yang you know it's
like I think I don't know what I don't
know I don't know it's like it's a man
and a woman [ __ ] you know a
cheeseburger and a biscuit right
you know what I got to tell you
something I was eating a lot of salads
this week all right and I got to give
something up to the old vegans they're
just as far as like you know some people
like you know this you need to eat meat
and that type of [ __ ] and then you got
other people going we were never meant
to eat meat our teeth are that like
horses they're straight across so we
should be eating leafy greens and beans
I gotta tell you something men I think
vegans are right on some level just hear
me out you go out you go get a big steak
dinner with some potatoes and you go
down there you go down there you go
[ __ ] eat like John Wayne Lee Mahmoud
you go down there okay in the next
morning okay when you're sitting there
[ __ ] grabbing the bottom of the bowl
underneath you're trying to get that
stuff to come out of you all right you
[ __ ] go out and get yourself a vegan
lunch if you just did that once a day
and then ate like John Wayne I think
you'd be fine because I'm telling you I
don't give a [ __ ] what you eat the rest
of the day if you go down and you get
one of those [ __ ] yoga pant breakfast
all right one of those Bruno's things
that you have you have like yoga mat in
the back of your chair you know and when
people say things to you the way you
emotionally react is you open your eyes
wider you know did you know they're
having a bake sale down the street you
just go hmm with your [ __ ] eyes
I'm telling you the next day like this
there's no there's no problems you just
wake up and that trains coming through
[ __ ] I couldn't think of a good song to
be singing Moon River it's [ __ ] it's
ridiculous so that's there's got to be
something to it and I know what you
think of Bill you can still eat eat
steak but you know you have a shell with
you a potato because when you applicator
with red meat all this is what makes it
no joy just shut the [ __ ] up you know
what I'm saying dude I eat like those
vegan at those places and like when I
leave I feel amazing like I'm floating
out of there I'm energized you know yet
relaxed I go down to a steak [ __ ]
place all right and you still feel good
when you walk out of there but it's more
like you know you walk in are they
holding on to the banister as you're
walking down the stairs I was actually
talking to us somebody yesterday on my
mandate and you know we were sitting
there drinking eating [ __ ] wings and
[ __ ] like well I don't even what the
[ __ ] we were watching at that point
because the stupid shoot took all day
long no sorry the shoot that I totally
respect took all day long and I was just
sitting there you know I was talking to
him you know cuz I've never had a shot
of that Johnnie Walker Blue
you know and I walked into a liquor
store yesterday see how much a bottle
was I was like 200 bucks it's like I'll
go [ __ ] yourself but I still want it
right and we were just sitting there
talking about that [ __ ] and I was just
like you know something I just realized
that was really depressing it's like
everything I really enjoy kills you you
know steak whiskey cigars I [ __ ]
trucks killing me you know that goddamn
exhaust I gotta warm it up because of
the Cabarita
all right I have it my garage
Oh Mon I got it I gotta wait till it
like gets all warmed up so I can drive
up my [ __ ] stupid driveway that's at
a [ __ ] 90-degree angle it was
designed for someone to drive a go kart
down like everything I'd [ __ ] like so
I need to eat more leafy greens people
that's what I'm saying I just a you know
something if you if you get a good one
it's just like anything else cuz there's
bad steak places you know those steak
places where if you have to put any sort
of like you know steak sauce on a on a
steak like that person doesn't know how
to cook it yeah I mean that's one of the
biggest insults you can do if you go to
a steak place and they put the steak in
front of you you have a couple of bites
and you go hey can I have some a one
sauce which I swear to god is like
Cologne with a little mesquite in it
like I don't understand [ __ ] a1 steak
sauce that is the worst sauce I mean how
could it be good how could a
mass-produce steak sauce be good that's
like you start doing that you have like
a [ __ ] that when you just have some
giant I don't know what that of the
ingredients you know you got like a dump
truck comes in to pour all the sugar in
it just you can't [ __ ] do it you need
a little old lady making it you know in
a little pot and then stick it in a jar
and selling it out of the back of her
[ __ ] rusted out Corvair or something
right what am I talking about talking
about steak sauce everybody I'm trying
to say how I want to [ __ ] I want to
eat better that's what I want to do he
what's great about eating eating like
that too is then you don't have to go to
the gym as much you can do it you do
push-ups a couple of pull-ups and you're
ripped you don't have to [ __ ] go down
to the goddamn gym and work off whatever
shall shut up all right summer plans
bill summer is around the corner do you
have any special plans with the lady um
I have a couple of plans this year and
neither involve my woman want one of my
own on my bucket list is I want to go to
the Galapagos Islands and I've decided
that I'm [ __ ] going
I don't know when but uh I found someone
who knows a bunch of [ __ ] about animals
so I can go there and not have to worry
if a komodo dragon charges me I want to
do that other than that one of my
special plans oh yeah I actually do have
some special plans but I'm not gonna
tell you what they are you know you
[ __ ] weirdo I tell you where I'm going
um yeah Galapagos Islands at some point
go ahead go down there and wait for me
all right chick advice hey Bill I'm 25
and I've been listening to your podcast
for a year now and I really enjoy it I
want to get your advice on my current
situation yeah I could have assumed all
of that because I'm arrogant and why
else would you write in okay after a lot
of failed relationships I wanted to try
a new approach of meeting women I met a
21 year old girl through my
sister-in-law and figured she was
interesting and pretty enough to
consider for a serious girlfriend we
started hanging out as friends so I
could be sure that I was in fact able to
be friends with her before I made a move
to something more seriously more serious
sorry things have been going well for
the last two months and we get together
a couple times a week to hang out and do
stuff Wow um last week I finally decided
that I wanted to make my move on her I
was saying goodbye to her after hanging
out and I finally moved in for a kiss
and she backed away it got really
awkward after that and she kind of said
oh I have to go about ten minutes later
I got a text from her saying sorry for
backing away
but I don't want to ruin our friendship
ah dude you [ __ ] waited too long the
cry woods goes go watch that Chris Rock
special where he ste does the friendzone
anyways he says what the hell do I do
now she has always been very flirty with
me the entire time we've been hanging
out oh wait she's been flirty with you
now [ __ ] her she works at an all-girls
camp during this summer and she always
hangs out with me on her days off so I
know there isn't anyone else she's
seeing all right first of all scratch
that
all right you have no idea what how does
that expression go
you know only the devil knows the
secrets in a woman's heart isn't that
how it goes something like that
don't ever [ __ ] you you have no file
I don't give a [ __ ] okay you could have
a woman in a goddamn cell you still have
no idea what the [ __ ] they're doing this
sorceress
[Laughter]
anyways am I to believe she is so naive
to think that we were just hanging out
as total platonic friends the only
reason I could think why she would do
that is because I am agnostic and she is
a semi religious girl what do you think
I should do you know what you should do
[ __ ] walk Robert De Niro in heat just
walk away all right
just walk away this is what you do all
right
this girl's being all flirty with you
and all that type of [ __ ] she gets you
dick hard you're trying to be a
gentleman you don't try to [ __ ]
finger blaster on the first day because
you think she's special all right so
three days after flying kites and going
on picnics you go in for a kiss she
pulls up ruin the friendship give me a
[ __ ] break she knows what the [ __ ]
she's doing all right she's toying with
you since this is what you do this is
the best thing that you can do when a
woman does something like that that
makes you want to go out and eat [ __ ]
sheet metal is you don't you don't give
them the emotion that they want which is
she day want you to be upset and I don't
know I don't know I don't know why I've
no I don't know [ __ ] why but she
wants you to be upset so this is what
you do okay you just say oh yeah hey I
didn't know what I was doing that's cool
that's cool whatever all right and be
like yeah absolutely
we could totally be friends all right so
don't try to [ __ ] bang her anymore
don't blow her off so she has no idea
what you're doing just keep hanging out
with there whatever doing this and that
and then we do just start [ __ ]
working out you get jacked right and
then on the side you start talking to
other broads and then one day you show
up with a [ __ ] goddamn hickey on the
side of your neck you know
and then you [ __ ] just don't even
address it what's that I you know I was
hanging out with some girl last night so
what are you doing
they just you just you mind [ __ ] right
back you fight fire with fire
that's what you do get on with your life
sir [ __ ] her that's it
alright that's it that's that's what I
feel my solution is always the same okay
is whenever a girl does some [ __ ] like
that
alright or if a girl breaks up with you
or anything like that and and if a girl
still wants to be friends with you after
she broke up with you don't alright you
get the [ __ ] away from her Hurt Locker
okay put on your bomb suit and [ __ ]
walk away don't be the don't be the hero
you [ __ ] walk away because they just
want to keep you in their life as they
slowly get over you and just constantly
be taking a steak knife and shoving it
into your heart [ __ ] that alright you
get away from them this does no point
being around this girl so right now this
girl just tried to mind [ __ ] you so if
you do matically just cut off being
around her she's gonna win on some level
and she'll actually get some sort of
level of satisfaction that you reacted
that way cuz because even though you
think you're saying [ __ ] you what you're
really saying is I actually cared about
you and that's gonna feed our goddamn
ego so don't do that so just be like
yeah I don't know what I was thinking
you know hey you can't yeah yeah you
can't blame a guy for trying
that'll annoy her like she's just some
piece of meat you took a swing at this
is such terrible [ __ ] advice but you
know what I believe in it
this is how I've lived my life if you
want to end up like me 43 not married no
kids that's how you do it you know I was
actually thinking of maybe adopt in one
of those Ugandan kids it's the perfect
[ __ ] thing he can do something beyond
that douche bag who made the movie is
you can actually help one of those kids
the kids already 12 years old alright
then you only have to be a parent for
six [ __ ] years and then he graduates
high school all right man have at it
good luck
um you know then I can catch right up to
all these other parents I have a 13 year
old oh I have a 12 year old yes I do got
three of them I got three of them I
don't even need a pit bull anymore these
[ __ ] can load and unload a gun
with their eyes closed
that's [ __ ] mean but it is what it is
what a [ __ ] did I go to from that from
that goddamn broad yes oh forget that
forget that girl
all right I don't know
yeah just whatever she wants to hang on
yeah hey let's hang out and don't be
weird around her don't be whipped
hey sorry about that I don't know I was
an idiot or whatever that's what you do
that's what you do all right then what
you do is start talking about some other
girl wait a couple of weeks and just say
hey you know I kind of met this girl I
kind of like her and but blah blah blah
blah you know this is this is a [ __ ]
this is the old hook and lateral play I
don't know if this will work this is
definitely a Hail Mary but maybe if you
[ __ ] start say hey and I met this
girl and I kind of like her you show up
with a hickey on your neck I don't know
what happens
there's spinal cord muscles the spinal
cord muscles the muscles around their
spinal cord get [ __ ] I they get weak
you know and all of a sudden they just
fall face-first into your lap sometimes
that happens you know but you're not
gonna know unless you try it all right
don't be Chris Webber and be looking to
pass the [ __ ] ball here you want to
take the shot you understand me so
that's what you do sometimes I say this
[ __ ] and I know I've stepped outside of
myself and I just realize what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I sound like but enough for some
reason you guys listen to this [ __ ] so
whatever what is it 47 minutes in 27
goddamn what is it 2:00 in the afternoon
there's daylight savings like we're a
bunch of goddamn farmers and we have to
get up early too for the crops sad what
it's all about
Oh last week by the way I went out I did
some investigative reporting on the not
reporting investigative cell phone pics
of the the Colonel Sanders sign and this
is what I found the one in Koreatown
Colonel Sanders definitely
looked a little more Asian than he does
the usual plantation owner oh right and
so I was convinced I was like goddamn on
you know Nia was right but somebody else
wrote in and said bill I've always
thought that the crook that the Colonel
Sanders looked Asian I think the older
logo for KFC has a more ethnic looking
yeah what is I don't understand what is
ethnic does that just mean non-white am
I not ethnic I don't [ __ ] understand
though I guess cuz I'm mixed is that
what it is I'm just a mutt but so are
african-americans right they're all
mixed in right that's an entire
continent of people all mixed together
the same way all as European Whitey's
are none of it makes sense
anyways I think the older logo for KFC
has a more ethnic looking kernel and the
newer ones don't
so maybe the one you and Nia see
sometimes just happens to be an older
sign here's the older one and he shows
the one the one that's hanging in
Koreatown and he goes here's the newer
one and that's the one I see everywhere
else but don't see it's kind of weird
though that they leave the the one that
kind of looked Asian too evidently mean
a lot of other people that they leave it
in Koreatown I don't think it's bad you
know I don't know you know what I'm
gonna put the I'm gonna put both
pictures up this week on the on the
podcast page and I'll let you guys
decide how about that there's this your
interactive web moment of the week do
you know if you actually go to my
podcast by the way let's all go to Bill
burr calm right now okay get off the
treadmill parachute out of your flight
and let's go to amazon.com and if you go
there like me evidently the [ __ ] I
want this load all right I got
amazon.com I got a window right
underneath the iTunes a banner the black
one that's the USA one and then I just
added two more one for Canada and one
for UK and basically if you'd like to
donate money to the podcast and the
Wounded Warriors Project this is the I
think this is the best thing we're doing
here is anytime you're gonna buy
something on amazon.com I'm not
if you're gonna buy something off of
amazon.com just go to bill bird calm
first click on the podcast page and if
you're in the United States that first
one right next to the left of the stamps
comm banner the black one you just click
on that and go on go buy something and
they'll give me a little kickback and
then I take 10% of the kickback and I
give it to the Wounded Warriors Project
and for Canada and England I don't know
what charities yet why don't you let me
know
tell me something over there that you
want me to give it to give me some
suggestions if it sounds like something
that is legit I'll kick some I'll kick
some pounds and some maple leafs over to
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
how's that does that work well that's
great is that the podcast for this week
am i or am i all out of I'm all out of
material oh my god so I gotta wing the
rest of this [ __ ] what else did I do you
want to know I've been doing you
probably want to know hey Bill what is a
guy who [ __ ] off for a living do when
he's on vacation you know what I've been
doing I've actually been working on 32nd
note fills on the on the drums it's just
something I've never been able to do
unless they're just lame right left
right left
thinkety thinkety could take it to dig
it again to getting it dig it again to
get it gonna get a good bang you know
but that [ __ ] will you start [ __ ]
breaking it up between the hands and the
feet and then there's sort of odd
groupings like groupings of five you
know what I mean
so when it went it when it starts to
repeat it just gets like all it almost
sounds like you're playing a different
time signature and you somehow come out
on the one I've been actually working on
that and I know this is unbelie--
excruciating ly boring to everybody else
in the podcast but that's what I've been
working on I've been working on two ones
that I got off of [ __ ] YouTube this
week and I've just decided that like
when I work on [ __ ] like in my stand-up
act where I just go I'm just gonna work
on this and bomb with this until I come
out the other [ __ ] side I've decided
that I'm gonna do that with these two
different fills because I'm sick and not
knowing how to do
I'm sick of hearing it in my head and
then be sitting down at a drum kit and
not being able to [ __ ] do it
and I don't know why this is important
to me I don't play in a band you know
TRL doesn't exist anymore so I don't
know where I feel like I'm gonna go with
this but yeah that's what the [ __ ] I'm
doing I just do that I've drank like
every day not a lot I just have like one
I sit down I'm becoming that guy I sit
down and I pour myself a glass of scotch
at the end of the [ __ ] night that's
what I do
I sit down and you know what's funny is
like that's like the original nyquil
though is if you have a scotch in the
middle of the day like I did yesterday
we were watching the Bruins right and
they will lose in and [ __ ] and I asked
my buddies if you want a beer he's like
no no not really
and I was goes why you gonna drink I was
like yeah and he was like all right you
know one of those deals takes you that
much to [ __ ] convince somebody to
drink and we both had one and the only
reason why I didn't just not off into an
old man nap immediately afterwards is
because he was sitting there and we
would laughing about it later I was
going through it I was like [ __ ] half
a second away from just sleeping for
three straight hours and my buddy
actually told me cuz he was sitting
outside a room I didn't see he actually
nodded off for a couple of [ __ ]
minutes that's something you know that's
the dumbest thing that I do is you know
I fight that old man afternoon nap I
fight it I don't know why I do there was
a period in my early 30s when I was
still living with bla Robert Kelly I got
into the zone with the old man naps when
we were living together and he would be
talking to me and we'd be right in the
middle of a conversation and I just look
at him and I would stand up and I'd walk
into my bedroom and just go to sleep and
he would just start [ __ ] laughing and
then within five seconds he was asleep
like [ __ ] two old dogs just passed
the [ __ ] out like we left the gas on on
the stove and then you just wake up
forty-five minutes later and I met one
time Bobby going like dude you call
those naps like [ __ ] I don't know
anyway like like clockwork and you felt
like a million bucks and for some reason
I have enabled to do that sense I always
fight him and then when I try and lay
down and do it I got too much [ __ ] going
on in my head now it's like that
meditating [ __ ] I used to be able to do
it I used to be able to do it and I
could feel and I'd float right out of
the room and it was [ __ ] awesome and
now what happens is right as I'm going
to that zone this voice in my head was
like okay here it comes it's gonna
happen
yeah and then it all goes away and then
it becomes frustrating and then I'm
meditating and I'm angry oh [ __ ] you
know what that reminds me of I have a
have I don't know have the EV the [ __ ]
blocks all been defined like the
different kind of [ __ ] blocks I don't
know if there's this name strim but I
got a new I got a new [ __ ] block for you
this will this [ __ ] block is very
special and a very obvious one and I
think like this happens all the time but
for some reason I've never heard anybody
name it so I'm gonna I'm gonna kick off
the creative process I call this guy the
announcer that's the that's that's the
name of this [ __ ] block this is what
happened to me I was I did a gig in
Jersey and at the end of the night these
two girls who waited to be at the back
of the line came up and they said hey
you want to go out and get banana
pancakes you know making a reference to
my joke saying if I wanted to go out and
hang out with both of them right and the
second they said it I was like holy [ __ ]
here's a [ __ ] here's something I
never had here's a two-on-one and I
can't [ __ ] do it cuz I'm with Nia
who's kidding no ku not cuz I'm with
Nia's because everybody's got a cell
phone [ __ ] camera and I get caught no
I couldn't deal with the guilt about it
I'll be honest with you and I would say
this if Nia was here if two [ __ ] tens
came up to me and said let's do this I
you know yeah [ __ ] it let's do it I
never did it
you know [ __ ] it so anyways so they said
hey you want to get out you want to go
out get bananas and pancakes or
something like that and then this
[ __ ] guy like 10 feet or a way just
goes like you know those guys like if a
girl just comes up to you just like you
know you know I've always loved guys in
green shirts and you're thinking raise
your thinking like holy [ __ ] this is
gonna happen there's some other guy like
five and just makes the whole fire out
of the whole [ __ ] room look over at
you the [ __ ] announcer [ __ ]
cock-block [ __ ]
you know who would do that if I was
standing there and her two girls say it
to a guy I'd be like god damn it's going
down right side of my mouth that lucky
[ __ ] I wouldn't be why would you
do that the [ __ ] announcer and if you
have a friend like that alright the only
way you can still hang out with them is
if he goes out if you guys are going out
trying to meet women he has to wear one
of those old ABC bright yellow Monday
Night Football sport coats and if the
girls Y be wearing that you'll see
you'll see and that'll be that would be
the funniest [ __ ] thing ever like if
somehow if he couldn't figure out the
joke and he just thought the coat looked
good and just the whole night you just
saw him anytime you heard in the you
know 10 feet away in the bar he just
looked over and you see this guy dressed
like Howard Cosell you'd be now that's
the announcer he's these the he's the
guy he can [ __ ] block from like he's
almost like a sniper if he wasn't so
[ __ ] loud he's at the same distance
as a [ __ ] marksman but uh he kills it
with with loudest oh my god did that guy
[ __ ] annoy me hey come here she just
came in shaking her head
what I am beyond to come on over here I
was just telling that story with that
guy cock-blocked me with those two
chicks out in Jersey when they were just
going I told you this story no no I
wasn't gonna do something this is the
thing but I just admitted yeah but this
is what I did admit if they were both
tens I would have done it I never had a
[ __ ] it to one one and you know
something would you be that mad if they
were both smokin hot and the cellphone
video got out the video doesn't even
need to get out when you got the
announced today the guy he just
literally goes like yeah nothing
why am i a jerk silk pajamas you know
what it's turning into a very honest
podcast I was very honest I said this is
the thing I said I couldn't I couldn't
deal with the guilt unless if they if
unless they were both Ted's if they're
both [ __ ] tense give me a break
let me tell you something if you hooked
up with Brad Pitt there's only so mad I
could get it's [ __ ] Brad Pitt okay
yeah okay you know what that would that
if I just if I just said some generic
good-looking guy if I just said some
generic good-looking guy and you and you
just said that that would have scared me
but the way you just acted like you had
Brad Pitt's phone number that doesn't
scare me
oh really okay it's going down if you
want to go live out on the street and
get the [ __ ] out of this house
absolutely but you're allowed to have
some sort of crazy 2-1-1 yes that's no
it isn't if you just you know because
you're thinking on it unlike like a very
basic level but if you're really but if
you really think about it just think
about it it makes sense bill you're not
gonna try to mind [ __ ] me into thinking
that it's okay for you to have some sort
of 2-1-1 and I can that's not no it's
not going down
yeah but women are beautiful where we
lust after you a totally mate
since you guys find like dicks are weird
they're gross it's all hanging out there
it's disgusting you don't want that you
know nothing you don't want that proven
time and time and again and your stand
up and in your podcast but that's that's
another discussion you know what you you
just set yourself up like you're gonna
make some huge point and then you just
tapped out you know nothing about women
but that's just another discussion and I
just don't want even get into that so
now what you just give me the face what
are you doing today lazy Kubrick over
the weekend
I'm working hard well you're in here and
your pajamas talking about two-on-ones
yeah well I have to do an hour's worth
of [ __ ] here I'm coming up on it an hour
in two minutes yeah I did because you
want to chime in didn't do it they
didn't have any this week okay look at
you I think you're a fan of this podcast
no I'm not listen it didn't go down all
right but I'm telling you right now Nia
if two tens come up to me it's going
down game set match really you're gonna
deny me that
can I just buy you some stuff Wow really
yes really not some sort of [ __ ]
basketball wife that can be placated
with material things to a point yeah
exactly
okay if I'm gonna be [ __ ] honest here
come on there's got to be something that
I can buy you know something this should
be our Valentine's Day all right for the
guy the guy Valentine's Day this is what
Valentine's Day should be every year is
the guy gets a two-on-one and then you
get some nice stuff well why can't I
cuz you don't like that what do you know
women don't like sex you don't find like
when you guys fantasize you think about
the guys in your life you don't think
about other things come on Nia just one
just give me one no you don't you don't
yeah because you don't want one you just
being childish no I'm not yeah you are
you do you say you think you think you
want to hook up with with Jake
Gyllenhaal and Brad face whatever the
[ __ ] his name is Brad Pitt Brad Brad
face Pitt you just think you do
see you know what to think about me is
is like you have to hook up with
somebody famous
I'm actually just regular people see I'm
down to earth with this [ __ ]
see that's I'm saying you like stuff you
like shiny shiny things this is the I
get a two-on-one and you get some some
cracked up face old man in Vegas like
Robert Redford like I used to be
good-looking when Nixon was in office no
that's not how ago she ating works now
you got to come with something else here
this is an equal relationship I wanted
to I could pin you down to the ground
right now and tickle you until you
passed out and it's not a [ __ ] thing
you can do about it with anything that's
how the world works Nia why do you think
America is on top because we're right
well because we could because because we
can blow you up more times so it's your
your physical presence that's what makes
it like an unequal relationship yeah cuz
I can beat you down but I'm smarter than
you
yeah so whatever physical power let me
ask you this what did you have are
trumped by my mental [ __ ] Goliath
Miss suck on that red what do you think
you're smarter than all that was good
though though you got a good one in and
now you're storming off I taught you
well
alright that's a podcaster this week
everybody I hope you had a good time
listening to it
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
over there and oh wait I forgot to
announce my my dates for the week
[ __ ] where the hell is it go to the
billboard.com hyping it once again you
click on shows I am going to be here's
some new ones last week I told you that
I was gonna be at the DuPont theater
with the police the DuPont Theatre in
Wilmington Delaware
uh-huh I'm gonna say this in a black
scent I'm gonna be at the Music Hall in
Troy New York on March 31st that first
date was March 30th the Tarrytown Music
Hall April 1st one of my favorite gigs
I've only done it once I think I
actually did that gig but I only
headlined at one time I have conquered
college in New Hampshire oh my god come
on down to Concord College I guess you
can get tickets cuz they're telling me
to hype it so that's I April 27th and
then we're all the way into June
everybody June 15th 16th and 17th I'm at
the San Jose improv The Improv in San
Jose California 15th 16th 17th jump on
that [ __ ] trolley take your life in
your hands come on down to the club June
29th 30th and July 1st I will be at the
improv in Ontario ah I'm an Ontario
California you [ __ ] guys better show
up I know what you're thinking right now
yo what you gotta get to an Ontario
[ __ ]
it's the traffic it has nothing to do
with Ontario it looks like every other
part of California it's a bunch of
[ __ ] strip malls and stucco houses I
haven't been out there in a long goddamn
time oh you [ __ ] Ontario that is
a deal-breaker right there
I know I'm gonna do I'm gonna go out
there Thursday afternoon I'll do the gig
and then I'll [ __ ] stay over Friday
no I won't I'm going back and sleep in
my own goddamn bed I'll fight the
traffic [ __ ] three nights in a row
Oh [ __ ] of a gig um then things are
looking up I'm at The Improv in West
Palm Beach
Florida come on people in Florida come
on out to the West Palm Beach Florida
improv July 13th 14th and 15th and if
that isn't racist enough next I'm going
to Orlando Florida this is my racist
tour I'll be there a September 7th 8th
and 9th with any luck the Jacksonville
Jaguars got a game I could drive up to
go see that and then September 21st 22nd
and 23rd I'm at The Improv in Brea
California and there you go everybody
those are the dates so far as you've
noticed those are all Club dates after
the three first ones but those are all
Club dates why you ask because I'm
writing my new hour all right it never
ends I just keep going so uh I think I'm
gonna learn how to shoot a gun this week
I'll talk to you about it next week all
right
that's it that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves did I say oh did I say all
the average' oh I forgot games like
gamefly.com everybody how could I forget
that this has been a monster for us
everybody enjoying gamefly are you a
gamer sure we all are would it be nice
to go would it be nice to have like
video games delivered straight to your
PC or right to your door have over 8,000
games to choose from well if you go to
Monday morning podcast listeners get a
15 day free top free free free trial go
to gamefly.com slash BER to activate
this special offer so there you go I'm
protecting your feet I'm filling up your
brain and you don't have to go to the
post office I don't know what else you
get what else do you want from me huh
well you tell me there's anything else
you'd like to get a discount on because
I kind of been doing that with these
people you know I just go hey what do
you sell what do you sell over there oh
you selling cadaver parts tell you what
if I can get anybody to buy a finger you
just kicked me two bucks per digit all
right and if nobody buys anything you
don't owe me [ __ ] so there you go so if
there's something out there you want to
[ __ ] discount on and I can make some
money off of it you let me know you let
me know all right I'm sick of saying
goodbye go [ __ ] yourselves
you